mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
in square abcd construct a quarter
circle centered at a whose radius is
equal to the side length of the square
construct a circle p inside the quarter
circle that is tangent to both the
quarter circle and the square
finally construct c e
such that c e is tangent to the
inscribed circle
the question is what is the measure of
angle ecd
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
recall that if two circles are tangent
their centers and the tangent point are
collinear this is because ac is
perpendicular to the tangent line and bc
is also perpendicular to the tangent
line therefore acb forms a straight line
segment this is true for both externally
and internally tangent circles now let's
solve the problem
we have a quarter circle centered at a
and we have an inscribed circle p that's
tangent to it
therefore a p and the tangent point will
be collinear
since a is a corner of the square this
line segment will also go through c the
other corner of the square
suppose the inscribed circle has a
radius equal to r
construct p q such that q is the tangent
point alongside a d
p q will have a length equal to r
now construct the perpendicular radius
which will also have a length equal to r
this means aq has a length equal to r
thus
ap is the hypotenuse of an isosceles
right triangle and its length will be
equal to r times the square root of two
we then have the radius of the quarter
circle is equal to r square root of 2
plus r
this means a d will have the same length
and thus qd must have a length equal to
r times the square root of 2.
now let's consider the diagonal of the
square
this must be equal to the square root of
2 multiplied by the side ad
we can substitute in for the length of
ad and then simplify
we know the length of ac and we know
that a portion of it is equal to r plus
r times the square root of two
therefore the remaining portion must be
equal to r
from here let's construct ce
since e is a tangent point we must have
pec as a right angle
then pe is equal to r because it's a
radius of the circle
now consider the right triangle pce
we have a hypotenuse that's equal to 2r
and a shorter leg that's equal to r
therefore the angle opposite r must be
30 degrees because this is a special
right triangle
this means pce is equal to 30 degrees
we can finally calculate the measure of
angle ecd
it'll be equal to angle acd minus angle
pce
angle acd is equal to 45 degrees and
angle pce is equal to 30 degrees
therefore angle ecd is equal to 15
degrees and that's our answer
it's a cute little geometry problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]